foreign
[Music]
thank you for inviting me to speak to
you today about our research and product
development my team is working out
Aspire Women's Health I am Dr Leslie
Northrup the chief scientific officer at
Aspire Women's Health and I'm a trained
molecular biologist and a clinical
molecular geneticist
as a scientist we are always reading
articles and journals in the field of
science that best fits the focus of our
research at this moment in time I also
like to find meaningful books in the
same subject matter recently I purchased
a book by Dr ozra Raza a well-known
oncologist at Columbia University
Medical Center and New York Presbyterian
hospital she's a leading expert on
leukemic cancers specifically mild
dysplastic syndrome there's actually a
section in the beginning of the book
that resonated with me and I wanted to
share as this is the focus of my team's
research and goals as it pertains to
developing new clinical diagnostic tasks
for ovarian cancer
the first bullet point I think really
resonates in that 30 to 40 percent of
all cancers can be cured today when
implementing a technology to detect
early markers of cancer such as somatic
DNA driver mutations epigenetic changes
cancer-specific RNA and proteins as well
as cancer-specific metabolites and
biological samples by employing
molecular techniques the second quote
that really resonated me was actually
re-quoted by Dr Bert vogelstein who is a
Pioneer in the field of oncology and
early detection of cancer
his statement is that 50 years from now
cancer deaths could go down 75 percent
just through prevention early detection
and development of newer strategies to
deal with early rather than late stage
disease
as you will find throughout the talk
this is where our team is focused on
developing clinical diagnostic based
tests for early detection versus late
detection and applying all these
molecular markers as mentioned
previously
so today this is our reality this is a
snapshot of all the challenges we are up
against in developing diagnostic tasks
for gynecologic cancers
we are dealing with a disease that has a
high mortality rate greatly unrecognized
and underfunded with a huge health care
costs the most critical factor is time
as you can see in the upper right hand
corner if the diagnosis of the cancer is
in late stage it only has about a 17
survival rate depending on the type of
histology detected
whereas if it's diagnosed early 90
survival rate so as you can see time is
on is the essence and it's really the
early detection and prevention is where
we're going to increase the survival
rate for women inflicted with ovarian
cancer
also another interesting fact is that
the greater incidence in death in
ovarian cancer versus breast cancer
breast cancer affects one in 10 women or
greater than one to two women die with
ovarian cancer
there's also an increased mortality in
different ethnic populations for
instance in black women versus white
women The Five-Year mortality rate is
higher versus white women and this is
really our Focus here at Aspire women's
health is that we are developing tests
for all women not One race or ethnicity
so the reason that most women are
detected in late stage is because of the
current tools used today to detect let
alone diagnose ovarian cancer is
inadequate
the first line of detection is clinical
assessment in the pelvic cavity an
inexual Mass must be large enough to
visualize by transvaginal ultrasound and
is subjective based on the clinician's
interpretation of morphology
characteristics
axle masses are a common clinical
finding and may present symptomatically
or incidentally
the majority of them are benign and most
can be confidently characterized by
ultrasounds however there is a small
percentage of those that presented
borderline tumors or invasive cancers
ultrasound is the first line Imaging
modality allowing the characterization
of most anaxial masses but not all
the problem is Imaging features
indicative of malignancy overlap with
benign pathologies there's a range of
diagnostic sensitivity of 67 up to 99
and specificity starting at 77 up to 99
percent
with these varying ranges subjective
interpretation it requires an on-visit
with an expensive medical assessment
sometimes no access to care multiple
women go undetected for too long
the second line of detection is blood
tumor markers the most recently the most
readily used biomarker is ca125 it's
been around for 40 years
it has a poor performance and it's best
at detecting late stage cancers and only
one histology epithelial ovarian cancers
with sensitivities ranging between 61 to
90 percent while specificity between 35
and 91 percent the third line of
detection is tissue analysis this is the
only true diagnostic which requires an
invasive surgery full removal of the
inaxial mass with pathology assessment
you cannot biopsy in exomass as it would
increase rupture risk and if a malignant
Mass would increase spread
currently clinicians utilize all three
of these Technologies to determine if a
woman is at risk of ovarian cancer
currently today the only screening which
I say lightly methodologies is through
hereditary genetic testing
however there is still a hindrance in
offering this testing for all as you
must present family and or personal
history to receive covered testing by
your insurance
if all women were offered genetic
testing we could mitigate risk early and
let women know to increase their
screening capabilities
brca being the most prevalent known and
most well-studied Gene as its Associated
risk with breast cancer first dinovarian
cancer however as you can see in the pie
graph on the left in combination with
hereditary and familial risk you're only
looking at about 20 percent of cancers
is due to a germline risk and the
majority of the cancers are actually due
to sporadic
sporadic findings
we need better diagnostic tools for
detecting these sporadic cancers
if you walk to the brca stats on the
right and you look closely one in 75 is
a lifetime risk of ovarian cancer in the
general population if you're carrying a
germline variant for the brca gene you
also have an increased 40 percent
lifetime risk for ovarian cancer and 15
percent of the ovarian cancer cases are
due to mutations in one of two genes
however as you can see outlined in the
red box there's currently no effective
routine screening tests for ovarian
cancer
and currently today if a woman is
identified with a positive brca variant
the tools used today were those covered
on the previous side with low varying
diagnostic accuracy
now we're going to turn over to the
technology
and it and here we have a very basic
schematic representation of the benefits
of liquid biopsy over tissue biopsy the
most obvious being is the invasive
versus minimally invasive approach
the greatest advantage of liquid biopsy
is the technology if it's developed
smartly with the right markers it can be
used as early detection
clinical diagnostic tests and when
tested in the correct patient population
it can be developed and validated as a
screening-based test
however with early detection there is
tremendous benefits but also poses
several challenges let's first review
the benefits
number one it has potential to remove
invasive tissue biopsy in the future it
provides a very safe and non-invasive
alternative with a simple blood draw
number two early detection is key
mortality rate can be reduced by 90 in
ovarian cancer which is a huge unmet
need in this patient population
number three it allowed to build upon
the population level screening data
collected to further refine the
screening methods to identify high-risk
women due to germline variants
however with everything in life benefits
always comes with challenges
currently in gynecologic cancer there is
no other screening test apart from the
pap smear for cervical cancer
and other guy enhancers specifically
ovarian cancer we are starting from the
beginning this is novelty and a new age
development in developing tasks that can
be an early diagnostic tool
specific to early detection the amount
of various analytes such as micro RNA
cell tumor DNA and proteins which I'll
go into further have such a low fraction
of quantities or signals that no single
analyte shows high enough performance
and detection and hence their
integration is highly recommended which
possesses its own Technical and
logistical issues such as integration
framework larger blood draw due to
multiple experiments Etc
third due to the small fractions of
detecting signal or amount of analytes
the biochemistry and detection pipelines
have to be highly sensitive and highly
accurate in order to remove false
negatives
and overall there's a lot of development
that is required in developing a liquid
biopsy-based test
however we don't let that deter us from
getting to our goal of developing a task
for early detection of wearing cancer
so for instance here's a nice example
another schematic showing you
differences in liquid biopsy targets
there are multiple biological targets
and analytes that can be used for these
purposes such as cell tumor cells immune
cells proteins cell free RNA DNA and
exosomes
these six different targets that can be
measured and Quantified for different
biological functions it's very
heterogeneous and so their integration
of their expression and Signal possesses
another technical problem
there are approaches being developed and
we will discuss these in the next few
slides
this is a heavy slide and I really just
want to go over the information here
from a high level and review a key main
points
versus is that the small percentage of
cell Breeze DNA is made up of cell tumor
DNA there's very early promise in
measuring cell tumor DNA as a diagnostic
therapeutic liquid biopsy detection test
lung cancer being the most promising to
date with the egfr gene that has
therapeutic targets
most prevalent detection is currently in
late stage cancer detection how can we
leverage this technology to work for us
in early stage detection
well there's things that we need to be
that are required in developing a test
of this nature one is it requires Ultra
sensitive methodologies at a very low
percent of tumor allelic fraction
it requires specific cell free DNA
concentration to detect early stage
cancers
There's issues that can arise because of
random fragmentation it can affect the
targeted enrichment of your libraries of
the genes in which you want to assess
for example PCR primer artifacts which
can compete with true variant detection
your panel targets is critical on the
efficiency and diagnostic accuracy and
what you include in your panel in the
liquid biopsy detection
this lies with limitations in developing
a pan cancer test whereas if you're
limited on your target content when
targeting multiple tissue types versus
one tissue type of cancer this arises
where it increases the economics of your
test for clinical Diagnostics as well as
limits the amount of targets that you
can have in your panel
so when designing a liquid biopsy-based
test the most crucial part is
development of the chemistry and the
target size of your panel on the right
here you'll see a schematic example of a
different type of Target capture using
ngs-based methodologies
really what you want to do is you want
to make sure that your targets are most
informative of the disease detection
that you're questioning you want highly
informative targets dictating treatment
specific association with a cancer type
as well as identify driver mutations of
the disease that leads towards treatment
design options such as mentioned earlier
with lung cancer and egfr mutations
we also want the technology to be cost
effective you want to ensure that you
can have high throughput Diagnostics and
a clinical paradigm
the most important being in the design
is these unique molecular indices or as
we call umis these are important to
include in your Chemistry design in that
so that you can rule out artifacts so
you can rule out sequencing as well as
PCR error rate artifacts versus the true
variant detection of disease
the other key component is you really
need to get down to a low tumor allelic
fraction however the error rate of PCR
and sequencing can come into play as a
key factor because the lower level of
detection of the variant is harder to
identify it's like finding a needle in a
haystack
and so one way to go about this is you
add these umis you can either do single
or dual Umi so you have them on either
end of the three and five Prime ends of
the PCR amplicons and utilizing these it
reduces the redundance it allows
redundancy to develop consensus between
the fragments and then it also allows
you to be able to clearly identify
artificially induced errors versus true
mutations from the same Soma
the second key component to consider is
the bioinformatics pipeline for example
here is a high level overview of the
bioinformatics pipeline that is industry
standard in NGS germline variant
analysis
this is a rather simplified Pipeline and
there's a lot of other steps that go in
between each component however there are
three main pillars you have your primary
your secondary and tertiary analysis
primary includes the library that's
loaded on the sequencer and
demultiplexing of the indices with
multiple quality control checks
once this is done it goes into secondary
analysis
includes major steps of alignment to
your reference genome predominantly used
today is the hg19 gr37 genome as well as
you will do your variant calling in the
secondary analysis of course this is a
very simplified as it's a very
computationally heavy and demanding
phase of the pipeline with somewhere
between 10 and 15 Steps
what you get at the secondary analysis
is a set of raw variances you then apply
these raw variances into your tertiary
analysis where you start to filter and
do The annotation and identification
against
well-utilized characterized data sets
from third parties such as Nomad to
really classify the variant annotation
as well as it's been observed in
affected populations to determine if not
it's a pathogenic variant
however I think it's important for us to
do a comparison of bioinformatic
pipelines for liquid biopsy versus the
standard used in germline detection
so here's a more detailed view you'll
notice there are three major differences
between a standard bioinformatic
Pipeline and the one which is used for
early detection of cancer such as cell
tumor DNA across the top you have the
four main steps alter deep sequencing
umis air detection and site-specific
thresholds the top representation of
sequencing data is showing you germline
sequencing bioinformatics where the
cell tumor DNA sequencing bioinformatics
the first difference is in the cell
tumor DNA pipeline requires Ultra deep
sequencing as compared to germline's
genomic DNA sequencing because you have
such a smaller amount of content of DNA
being swapped off from the tumor in the
blood
secondly the umras are the most
important design of the chemistry to
confirm a true call they differentiate
the PCR errors from a genuine variant in
the sample
then third is the error correction
realignment to match to the correct
break points differentiates the true
from artifact similar to realignment
around indels as detected in germline
detection
finally in cell tumor DNA pipeline a
hard-coded mutant allele fraction
threshold to classify variants as true
calls or artifacts and the underlining
idea is that the different mutations
have different mutation frequencies and
one threshold won't work for all
setting a hard-coded allelic fraction
for identifying rare variants is a
common practice in germline pipeline
however this won't work in cell tumor
DNA pipeline
so now I'd like to transition the talk
to highlight all the different
biological markers that can be detected
in liquid biopsy detection and they're
used in research in clinical Diagnostics
the first biological Target I would like
to focus on is micro rnas we should all
be well aware of what micro rnas are and
their prevalence in biology as well as
in clinical Diagnostics they are short
non-coding RNA rnas that play many
important roles including oncogenic and
tumor suppressive regulation
the beauty of measuring micro rnas for
clinical diagnostic is the disability
they are actually very Hardy biological
targets and can survive multiple freeze
thaw
um requirements as pertain in blood
sampling
they're also a lower cost technology
that can be developed to detect micro
rnas
you can streamline your technology to be
more cost effective and high throughput
for clinical diagnostic as compared to
nts-based Technologies
also there's a unique expression profile
between normal cells and cancer cells
interrelation in relation to one another
you can identify a unique profile for
specific cancer types higher expression
and this then would solidify a biomarker
of cancer detection
the second biological Target is protein
proteins has actually been a market
that's been well established and been
around for a long time as it pertains to
diagnostic tools for cancer and the most
common one being used today is ca125
individual protein markers are
significantly Limited in terms of
sensitivity and specificity and they are
associated with a high false positive
rate
multiple protein markers can improve the
diagnostic and prognostic accuracy by
reducing the number of both false and
positive and false negatives
that's why one protein usually signifies
one histology or subcancer type and it's
important to utilize multiple proteins
in order to be sure that you have a
higher sensitivity and specificity as
well as to be sure that you're
diagnosing different histologies of
cancers for the disease in question
proteins are really more of an addictive
of a Global Response of cancer as stated
one protein can detect only one subtype
of histology of cancer and today in our
technology we utilize multiple proteins
or is like we we like to say a
multimodal approach to be sure that we
are able to have a high sensitivity and
high specificity of cancer detection as
well as different histologies of ovarian
cancer
so as you can see there's a need for
multiple biomarkers
as stated earlier no single analyte has
a diagnostic sensitivity for gynecologic
cancer detection and in order to be a
diagnostic-based test the rule of thumb
is it has to be greater than 95
sensitivity and 95 specificity if you
want a well screening based test the
rule of thumb is that you want around a
specificity in the general healthy
controlled population
a multiplex of biomarkers increases this
precision and accuracy of cancer
detection in the blood
also it requires an enriched machine
learning AI algorithm approach to be
able to parse out these complex
relationships between the markers and
weight them in a way so that we can show
significance of disease detection from
non-disease States
here's a nice example of a proposed
framework for integrating multiple
analytes and their quantities fraction
and scores to increase the detection of
performance with their sources analyze
some features that could be used so for
example in the first stream it's
important that we could take in clinical
data which includes the patient's
personal information it could be
symptomology family history different
hormone levels their race and ethnicity
then also looking at multiple proteins
like we stated earlier a single protein
is not weighted high enough on
diagnostic accuracy so utilizing
multiple proteins which can create a
risk score to better stratify risk of
disease
can also look at Gene panels look at the
germ line look at individuals who are
carriers and variants in the germline
and how can that be also combined with
risk of other multiple multiple
modalities to ensure a diagnostic based
test
as well as micro rnas as we touched upon
earlier and metabolites and by utilizing
all of these different analyte targets
and perform a priori feature selection
to identify which of these biomarkers
are most powerful in classifying disease
you can rank them based on most to least
significant we can perform standard
machine learning steps like building the
model training and testing to finally
classify the sample as having cancer
benign risk
in the next slide I will discuss a more
specific machine learning approach
and these are the applications that we
are currently using today in developing
our clinical Diagnostics based tests
so here's a primary example of a machine
learning algorithm for disease risk and
diagnosis that we're utilizing in our
Laboratory
we're focusing on clinical diagnostic
development I'm building machine
learning algorithms that use protein
biomarkers concentrations to determine
early ovarian cancer risks paired with
clinical assessment
we're currently exploring other
biomarkers as mentioned earlier such as
micro RNA expression levels genes and
we're also looking into exosome
detection to be able to improve our
early detection of ovarian cancer risk
assessment and move towards a more
diagnostic device
currently our most promising risk
assessment algorithm uses deep neural
networks to stratify protein biomarker
concentrations into a high and low risk
of malignancy in patients that present
within a maximal mass a spiral is
collecting specimens from massless
patients with asymptomatic patients
healthy controls and general population
to improve our machine learning
algorithms and the specific aim of
improving early stage ovarian cancer
detection
this slide gives you a nice snapshot of
the benefits of utilizing machine
learning and AI for clinical Diagnostics
as you can see there's a nice
representation on the left here showing
you the complexities that's utilized in
machine learning and neural networks
that can better recognize patterns in a
more higher dimensional space each one
of these Dimensions can be weighted on
their significance and be can be parsed
out on whether or not they can be
utilized as a true marker of detection
of disease versus normal
these patterns among the levels of many
biomarkers such as microrna genomic
targets Etc can be utilized in this
machine learning algorithm and we can
utilize this to better patient
evaluation than a clinical assessment
alone
in using AI machine learning it's we can
use it to develop novel techniques and
to solve for women diseases early rather
than late
and to close this is really where we're
going as an institution is we really
want to come up with technology that is
simple ease of use has lower economics
and we can Target all of these multiple
markers in one sampling and the future
is exosomes in clinical Diagnostics
currently access homes are being
utilized in therapeutic approaches
primarily in drug delivery methods there
are complexities still today and
purifying exosomes for clinical
diagnosis use and the technology is
still being developed for this purpose
however in the meantime we're working on
early development on how best to utilize
these secretory vessels that house all
the targets that we want to measure for
cancer detection as discussed previously
such as proteins micro RNA RNA
interleukins Etc and the beauty of this
is it would allow us one blood sample
one vesicle and one test to Target one
diagnosis starting with ovarian cancer
so I would like to thank my team for all
of their hard work and preparation for
this talk today as you can see I have an
enriched team of scientists from
bioinformatics r d data science as well
as a clinical team it's really important
when you're developing clinical
diagnostic tests that you have a strong
R D team that can develop the tasks and
and translate that over to a clinical
team that can validate it for clinical
use
um
and thank you for your time today I
appreciate it